[Musica]
che ruolo giocano l'italia el'europa
nella politica internazionale e che
ruolo giocano gli stati uniti
di solito per rispondere a queste
domande si guarda ai rapporti di forza
sullo scacchiere internazionale cioè al
modo in cui il potere è distribuito tra
gli stati gli stati più forti o quelli
con maggiori capacità militari ed
economiche di solito dettano le regole
quelli più deboli si adeguano se non lo
fanno
subiscono le conseguenze oggi vorrei
proporre una soluzione alternativa una
soluzione basata sull'idea di carisma
voi mi chiederete che c'entra il carisma
con la politica internazionale e come il
carisma può essere un'idea utile a
risolvere a liszt risolvere il caos
globale in cui ci troviamo
beh io sostengo che l'idea di carisma
può essere utile perché ci apre lo
sguardo a una particolare visione del
mondo di più differenti concezioni e
significati del termine carisma possiamo
assegnare differenti visioni del mondo
nell'arco della storia europea e
internazionale
allora quello che vorrei fare invitarvi
a un viaggio un viaggio due tappe un
viaggio alla scoperta di diverse visioni
del mondo di diverse idee di carisma
nell'arco della storia europea
la prima tappa di questo viaggio è
chiaramente max weber il padre della
sociologia moderna è quello che inventa
l'idea moderna di carisma e il modo in
cui usiamo il termine carisma oggi nel
linguaggio comune
weber pensa che il carisma sia un
attributo di leadership
il carisma è un tipo di autorità
politica lui lo definisce una qualità di
un individuo in virtù della quale
quell'individuo è considerato come
straordinario come se fosse dotato di
poteri addirittura eccezionali sovrumani
dice weber ma questo vuol dire che per
weber e il carisma e una questione di
qualità percepite o credute straordinari
significa che tu puoi anche essere
dotato di virtù eccezionali ma sei
carismatico solo se un altro attribuisce
senso quelle virtù gli altri
attribuiscono senso quelle virtù in
fondo questa idea funziona perché
abbastanza intuitiva se ci pensate noi
nel linguaggio di tutti i giorni siamo
abituati a dire magari che un'opera
d'arte e carismatica un leader politico
a volte perfino un personaggio dello
sport ma se io vi chiedessi che cos'è in
particolare che rende queste figure o
addirittura l'opera d'arte carismatica
weber ci dice ok sono una serie di
qualità che noi percepiamo come
carismatica ma quali sono allora questo
è il problema dell'idea weber janadi
carisma e quello che noi chiamiamo l'it
factor quelli che sta proprio a
significare un incognita una specie di
virtù misteriosa che se la possiedi
allora sei carismatico beh quale in più
c'è un altro problema quello del carisma
autoritario
beh se non solamente una questione di
qualità percepite o credute
straordinarie se non conta tanto quello
che fai ciò che sei ma conta come gli
altri ti vedono conta come gli altri
attribuiscono al significato a ciò che
fai a ciò che sei
beh allora se un leader carismatico
finché hai un seguito se un leader
carismatico finché gli altri ti pensano
carismatico potete immaginare il
problema qui e se pensate al rapporto
tra l'europa e gli stati uniti alla fine
della seconda guerra mondiale e
chiaramente gli europei cedono porzione
della propria sovranità nazionale cedono
la leadership sul continente europeo al
gigante americano
ma quali sono queste qualità americane
queste virtù eccezionali che noi
riconosciamo come straordinarie forze le
capacità economiche quelle militari
forze addirittura le capacità culturali
beh questo è il problema con la
definizione di carisma ma weber ci dice
aspetta forse non ti so dire con
precisione quali sono quelle qualità ma
ti so dire come quali sono le condizioni
favorevoli per vederle per scoprire
queste qualità allora sono due
condizioni una è una crisi di emergenza
e l'altra è una visione profetica del
futuro seconda guerra mondiale ancora ad
esempio l'europa è chiaramente in una
condizione di emergenza devastata sotto
tutti i profili ma non c'è una sola
visione profetica del futuro ce ne sono
due cioè la visione degli stati uniti ma
c'è la visione sovietica in fondo anche
i sovietici possono vantare capacità
militari anche i sovietici vantano
capacità culturali ed economiche cosa ci
spinge perché finiamo sulla sponda
americana che cosa ci impone una visione
americana del mondo
e allora il mio argomento e che per
rispondere a questa domanda
dobbiamo arrivare alla seconda tappa del
nostro viaggio all'idea di carisma
secondo san paolo san paolo innanzitutto
vede il carisma al plurale in greco
carisma da doni dello spirito fatti a
tutti gli uomini per l'edificazione
dell'umanità cristiana ma questo
significa e vedete subito la differenza
con weber che non si tratta tanto delle
qualità di uno e di come vengono
percepite dagli altri si tratta di doni
condivisi tu puoi anche avere dei doni
straordinario ognuno di noi ha dei doni
straordinari individualmente ma quei
doni hanno senso se li mettiamo in
comune se li mettiamo al servizio di una
visione comune allora san paolo ci aiuta
a vedere
nell'esempio che abbiamo fatto prima
della seconda guerra mondiale perché il
capitalismo vince sul comunismo laddove
impone una visione comune laddove impone
un'istituzionalizzazione di questi doni
di queste capacità straordinarie pur
diverse
ma tutte concentrate nella visione di
una prospettiva comune con la banca
mondiale la nato con le istituzioni che
gli stati uniti fondano in quegli anni
in qualche modo gli stati uniti
inventano quello che possiamo chiamare
il corpo carismatico della comunità
internazionale
voi vi starete chiedendo
l'europa oggi non funziona tanto come
una comunità politica carismatica
a dirla tutta non sembra neanche tanto
una comunità politica non sembra avere
una identità politica comune ed è qui
che io penso che l'idea paolina l'idea
di san paolo di carisma può essere
davvero utile anche se siamo arricchiti
si dai toni del gigante americano non
siamo riusciti a trovare un'identità
comune perché sanpaolo insiste san paolo
ci dice che carisma viene da caris
l'etimologia di carisma viene da kari
skies significa doni o favori
incondizionati liberi cioè non mediati
da interessi o meriti propri significa
anche un favore non dovuto qualcosa che
non ci è dovuto
e per questo significa che quando
riceviamo un favore di questo tipo ci
sentiamo in obbligo di restituirlo
allora ancora vedete come san paolo ci
impone di pensare il carisma ci dice che
essere carismatici
in realtà significa innanzitutto
riconoscersi in quei doni e riconoscere
la necessità di doverli restituire e
ancora di più riconoscere e accettare il
fatto che quei doni li abbiamo ricevuti
forse non per meriti nostri un esempio
interessante per per darvi un'idea di
come funziona questa questa visione del
carisma e quello dell'ospitalità
nell'antica grecia saprete sicuramente
che gli antichi greci avevano questo
concetto dell'ospitalità come di una
cosa sacra l'idea era che la visita di
uno straniero nella tua casa nella tua
città
rappresentava una sorta di dono divino
ti sentivi in obbligo sacro di dover
ricambiare questo favore di vino infatti
un s un episodio molto comune nella
mitologia greca e quella di un dio
travestito da straniero che bussa alla
tua porta all'inizio la città la tua
casa all'inizio 6 reticente non lo
accoglie ma poi è ospitandolo che
diventi carismatico in questo senso
anche nei vangeli l'arcangelo gabriele
bussa alla porta di maria maria
all'inizio reticente
ma e ospitando l'angelo e accettando il
dono dell'angelo che maria diventa
carismatica nel senso paolino che maria
diventa madre di dio allora quando lo
straniero bussa alla nostra porta
il dibattito se permettete povero
politico europeo ed italiano ci
costringe a questa visione a questa
dicotomia da un lato quelli che
necessariamente vogliono chiudere le
barriere che vogliono spingerci verso
un'idea di comunità nazionale di
sovranazionale chiusa e dall'altro
un'apertura assolutamente indistinta
delle barriere dei confini senza regole
ma queste se vediamo questa storia
questo è quello che ci sta accadendo con
una visione paolina queste due spinte
non sono necessariamente contrapposte
vanno semplicemente riordinata perché
senza l'apertura e la condivisione la
comunione senza il carisma paolino
quello che resta è semplicemente la
subordinazione al potere americano è
semplicemente il carisma di weber senza
l'apertura di una comunità europea
politica effettiva senza la presenza di
un effettiva comunità politica non
possiamo aprirci ma aprire fondare una
comunità politica che sia carismatica
significa anche aprirsi e arricchirla
con idonei che provengono dal
allora per chiudere il carisma di san
paolo ci impone una visione che va oltre
la semplice reciprocità di interessi
materiali è un amico e una visione che
per chiudere con le parole di martin
luther king è creatrice e redentrice una
visione di buona volontà per l'umanità
intera
grazie
[Applauso]